well earlier we spoke to Ptolemy brahim
he says Turkey should focus on dialogue
with the Syrian government to resolve
the situation on the border the Syrian
government is not so happy in what
Syrian democratic forces are doing and
indeed they are enemies to the Syrian
government and we know that they are
separatist and they want to make their
own entity and to divide Syria but the
treatment of this situation
I mean sidon democratic forces and other
Kurdish groups which are in the eastern
of your view practiced not by coop and
Syrian lands it is by working with civil
government to put an end to that and I
think Turkey can be a political means
and by cooperation with Russia Syria was
Iran and will others to end the
situation and this is of course a
situation a terrible situation the
eastern of Euphrates and nobody in
Damascus agrees Syrian democratic forces
but everybody is angry here from the
Turkish occupation and the Turkish
aggression against Syrian territories
woven cloth territorial aggression or
whether it was by airstrikes let's not
bring in my uncle Berlin he's the
director of policy analysis the Arab
Centre for research and Policy Studies
at the Doha Institute for Graduate
Studies he's joining us right here in
Doha thanks very much for speaking to us
on the al Jazeera news hour let's just
start out with what with what the vice
president of Turkey had to say just
about 30 minutes ago and one of the
things he was outlining while speaking
in Bursa is that he said this is a first
step of other steps we know that this
operation started in Tel Abyad and under
Osanai and so does it sound to you like
this is going to continue and how deep
will
turkey go into Syrian territory yeah it
might be a lengthy process in which
Turkey will be actually moving slowly
and taking down one by one of the
- forces in the north of Syria actually
the positions of the Kurdish forces in
the northeast of of Syria we all know
actually that Turkey has from the very
beginning requested that they Col like
into 30 to 40 kilometres deep into
Syrian territories but the Americans
have always actually opposed this this
proposal by Turkey and they were saying
that we they were willing actually to
accept something like between five and
seven kilometers deep into Syrian
territory and only on the strip of land
that actually goes between tilapia and
jarabulus meaning 140 kilometers long
along the borders between Syria and and
Turkey turkey on the other hand is
thinking that this operation should go
actually along the borders and the ease
of the authorities from jarabulus on the
Euphrates River to punish thee in the
far northeast so we still need to know
actually what sort of agreements the
Turks and the Americans have reached
concerning this this operation and when
it comes to the international reaction
we're now hearing that the NATO chief
has urged restraint from Turkey in the
Syria operation and we've also heard
that countries from the EU have called
for a Security Council meeting tomorrow
but when you look at who hasn't said
anything that's Russia clearly an ally
of Syria and the Syrian President how do
you explain Russia's silence well
actually Russia I mean normal situation
Russia would oppose I mean the Turkish
military operation and the north is of
Syria but what the Russians are doing
right now actually that they are trying
to be more flexible with the Russian
operation why because I think the
Russians want on the one hand to punish
the Kurds for aligning themselves with
the United States on the other hand to
push them back to embrace the Syrian the
Syrian regime so I think the Russians
are not very unhappy with the with
the Turkish operation in my opinion I
beg your pardon but the Russians as well
as the the Iranians and Turkey in the
past have all agreed to the importance
of unity when it comes to Syrian
territory yeah that that's absurd you're
absolutely right I mean Turkey is also
saying that this operation in order to
prevent the breakup of Syria because
turkey believes that the Kurdish the YPG
they call it actually the Syrian PKK is
having an is is having an ambition to
have a separate state in the northeast
of Syria and that and that it what
Turkey is trying to prevent right now by
this military operation of course I mean
Turkey Iran and Russia have their
disagreement on so many issues because
the ideal situation for Russia and Iran
is for the United States to do it draw
from East from the northeast of Syria
and the Syrian regime recovered that
territories instead but right now it's
not gonna it's not going to work like
that
it's the Americans that they are they're
the Americans they are allowing the
Turks to go inside Syria the Russians
they can't do much about it but they are
trying to take advantage actually in
order to change the dynamic of the
alliance in the region by getting that
Kurdish forces back to the Syrian regime
and back actually under the Russian
umbrella and break up this alliance
between the Kurds and the Americans that
is what the Russians are trying to do
right now and also the Russians are
trying to keep Turkey close to them
because turkey is very important for the
Russian Ashley scheme considering the
political solution in Syria don't forget
that after all Russia Iran and and
Turkey are partners in the eternal
process and the Zatanna process process
has succeeded in recent weeks in
establishing the constitutional
committee which supposed actually to
start convening late this month in order
to start talking about the drafting of
the Syrian resolution as a first step
towards political solution in Syria so
the Russians are trying to keep Turkey
close to them the Americans also are
trying to keep Turkey close to them and
the one who's and so what would have
been so what could have been
sort of the the parameters of this
Agreement that you mentioned between
Turkey and the Americans when it comes
to this operation well I think that that
the Americans they allow the Turks
actually to go inside Syria because as I
said earlier the turkey has been has
been trying actually to put huge
pressure on the Americans in order to -
I mean to accept the sort of Turkish
intervention in the north of Syria in
order to eliminate the Kurdish forces
but of course I mean Turkey is
presenting it as as an operation to
eliminate also ISIL Turkey now has
decided that they will take the
leadership of this operation against
ISIL and that was and that was the
approach actually they use in order to
convince President Trump that you don't
have actually to deal with the ISIL
anymore you don't have to deal with the
Kurdish forces in Syria anymore you
don't have to keep your forces in Syria
anymore we will take over the
responsibility we will fight ISIL but on
the same time we will actually fight the
YPG and the separatist ambition in the
northeast of Syria that is that is right
now how we see things in between Russia
between sorry between the United States
and Turkey and the SDF has also appealed
to the United States speaking of the
Americans for a no-fly zone it's saying
to protect it from Turkish attacks in
the northeast of Syria do you what's the
likelihood of that actually happening
that's not going to happen in my opinion
because turkey is a NATO ally so we
don't expect the Americans actually to
establish a no-fly zone in order to
protect them from from from from a NATO
partner
president Trump yesterday he said Turkey
is a very important trade partner for
the analysis and a very important NATO
NATO partner also for de for the West so
my hunch is that the the US president
decided actually to sell out the Kurds
and this in this equation because when
he is actually when he had to choose
between Turkey and the course he decided
clearly to go with with Turkey and that
is that is that is realpolitik
at the end of the day and that is
president tropopause who knows that the
rules of the game and how how things
this is how we use
politics very much like like he's using
the market as a businessman and on the
issue of ISIL fighters that you were
mentioning a moment ago a real concern
by people over in the Pentagon and also
around Trump who say this could we could
see a resurgence of ISIL in the area but
are we any clearer on what at what
turkey actually plans to do with the
ISIL members and how it will deal with
that well I think that was the agreement
as we understand from between President
Trump and president Erdogan they made
that agreement over the border over a
phone call we know now that both
actually the Secretary of Defense of the
United States and the chief of staff
they both actually were present during
that phone call which means actually
that the president has their support to
his agreement with President Erdogan
president Erdogan seem to have pledged
that he will be actually fighting ISIL
instead of the United States instead of
that and I think that was Turkey's
mistake from the very beginning had
turkey agreed actually to fight ISIL
since 2014 2015 when President Obama at
that time actually offered to have to
choose Turkey and the Syrian opposition
factions at that time but turkey decided
not to do that because Turkey was more a
cube I do more break about at that time
with the Kurdish question with with the
challenge of the Kurdish fractions in
the northeast of Syria now turkey
decided that we will go against ISIL we
will take this responsibility so the
Americans don't need actually to stay in
Syria and pay the cost of staying in the
northeast of Syria but that that's going
to be on the expense of the Kurds in my
opinion all right so I'm gonna walk
around we'll leave it there for now we
thank you very much for speaking to us